ahora vamos a hablar sobre la
elasticidad precio de la demanda que
parece un concepto muy sofisticado pero
en realidad es una forma que tienen los
economistas de saber qué tan sensible es
la cantidad en este caso demandada con
respecto a cambios en los precios
denotamos esto con la letra en mayúscula
su fe es la elasticidad de precio de la
demanda que es esta de de arriba la
forma más sencilla de pensar en esto es
que es el cambio porcentual usamos la
letra griega delta que significa cambio
el cambio porcentual en la cantidad
entre el cambio porcentual en el precio
y quizás se pregunten cómo se relaciona
esto con el concepto que tenemos de
elasticidad imaginen dos bandas una es
inelástica y la otra es elástica si
aplicamos cierta cantidad de fuerza a la
banda inelástica no podremos estirarla
mucho se estirará muy poco mientras que
si aplicamos la misma cantidad de fuerza
a la banda elástica ésta se va a estirar
mucho más la analogía aquí es que no
aplicamos fuerza sino que nos
preguntamos qué tanto van a estirarse
estas cantidades demandadas para
distintos cambios en el precio
algo cuya cantidad demandada cambia
mucho para cierto cambio en el precio
será muy elástico la magnitud de esto
será más grande y si el porcentaje de la
cantidad no cambia mucho para cierto
cambio porcentual en el precio de algo
entonces tendremos que la elasticidad
precio de la demanda es inelástica
comprenderemos mejor esto conforme
vayamos trabajando con las cantidades y
vamos a hacerlo con esta tabla de
demanda que tenemos aquí y que podemos
visualizar con esta curva de demanda en
el eje vertical está el precio de las
hamburguesas y en el eje horizontal está
la cantidad en términos de hamburguesas
por ahora vamos a usar esta fórmula de
la elasticidad precio de la demanda para
calcularla en estos puntos de la curva
de demanda agregamos la columna de la
elasticidad precio de la demanda vamos a
calcular esto usando el método más
sencillo que hay en futuros vídeos
veremos métodos un poco más detallados
como el método del punto medio también
les mostraré el punto débil de lo que
estamos haciendo aquí pero digamos que
para un curso introductorio de
macroeconomía este método será
suficiente
ahora calculemos
el precio de la demanda cuando pasamos
del punto a al punto b
recordemos que será el cambio porcentual
en la cantidad entre el cambio
porcentual en el precio cuál es el
cambio porcentual en la cantidad
comenzamos con una cantidad de 2 que
ponemos en el denominador y pasamos de 2
a 4 por lo que sumamos 2 tenemos 2 entre
2 que multiplicamos por 100% lo que nos
da un 100% de cambio en la cantidad esto
lo dividimos entre el correspondiente
cambio porcentual en el precio a que
será igual esto si el precio inicial es
9 y pasamos de 9 a 8 esto disminuye una
unidad que multiplicamos por 100% en el
denominador tenemos un cambio aproximado
de menos 11% y este cálculo es bastante
directo porque cancelamos estos 100%
esto es un 1 y 1 entre menos un noveno
va a ser igual a menos 9 tenemos un -9
de elasticidad precio de la demanda
antes de pasar a la interpretación de
esto vamos a calcular la elasticidad
precio de la demanda que hay de otro
punto a otro en esta curva
calculemos la elasticidad del punto a al
punto f vamos a hacer lo mismo cuál es
el cambio porcentual en la cantidad la
cantidad inicial es 16 y pasamos de 16 a
18 por lo que aumenta 2 unidades 2 entre
16 por 100 por ciento este es el cambio
porcentual en la cantidad y cuál es el
cambio porcentual en el precio bueno
el precio inicial es 2 y pasamos de 2 a
1 por lo que aquí tenemos menos 1 el
cambio porcentual en el precio es de
menos 1 x 100% aquí arriba tenemos un
octavo por 100% que es 12.5 por ciento
en el numerador y en el denominador
tenemos menos 50% cuando el precio
disminuye 50% hay un incremento en la
cantidad demandada de 12.5 por ciento
12.5 por ciento es una cuarta parte de
50% por lo que esto nos da una
elasticidad precio de la demanda de
menos 0.25
aquí hay un par de cosas interesantes
que quizás ya hayan notado uno es que
aún cuando aquí la curva de demanda es
una recta con una pendiente constante
podemos ver que la elasticidad precio de
la demanda es diferente en las
diferentes partes de la curva la razón
de esto es básicamente matemática cuando
pasamos de aaa ve los precios iniciales
son relativamente altos aunque el precio
disminuye en una unidad
el precio inicial es 9 por lo que el
cambio porcentual en el precio es
bastante bajo mientras que el cambio
porcentual en la cantidad demandada es
alto porque pasamos de una cantidad
menor de 2 a la que se le agregan 2
unidades por lo que tenemos un 100% de
aumento en la cantidad cuando llegamos
al otro extremo de la curva y pasamos de
a efe sucede lo contrario el precio
inicial es menor por lo que el cambio
porcentual en el precio cuando el precio
disminuye en una unidad parece una
cantidad grande mientras que el cambio
porcentual en la cantidad cuando pasamos
de a efe como ya nos encontramos en una
cantidad de 16
algo esto no va a generar un porcentaje
muy grande
otra cosa que quizás ya haya notado es
que si tratamos de calcular la
elasticidad precio de la demanda en esta
parte de arriba de la curva si pasáramos
dv
en lugar de a b obtendríamos un valor
diferente porque las cantidades
iniciales del precio y la cantidad son
diferentes en el precio inicial
hubiéramos puesto un 8 aquí y en la
cantidad inicial hubiéramos puesto un 4
acá por lo que el resultado sería
diferente esta es una de las debilidades
de esta técnica la cual es la técnica
más simple que podemos usar otras
técnicas como la del punto medio pueden
darnos un resultado más consistente sin
importar que pasemos de ave o de uve
pero aún no veremos esa técnica ahora
pensemos en cómo interpretar esto la
mejor forma de interpretarlo es pensar
en los valores absolutos de la
elasticidad de los precios de la demanda
aquí el valor absoluto de la elasticidad
precio de la demanda es igual a 9 y acá
abajo el valor absoluto de la
elasticidad precio de la demanda es
igual a 0.25
una regla general es que si el valor
absoluto de la elasticidad precio de la
demanda es menor a 1 tenemos una demanda
inelástica y si el valor absoluto de la
elasticidad precio de la demanda es
mayor a 1 entonces la demanda es
elástica porque tiene sentido esto bueno
en el primer escenario nos dice que para
un cambio porcentual en el precio
tenemos un menor cambio porcentual en la
cantidad mientras que en este otro
escenario para un cambio porcentual en
el precio vamos a tener un mayor cambio
porcentual en la cantidad
nuevamente regresamos a la analogía de
estas bandas cuando pasamos de a a b
tenemos que el valor absoluto de la
elasticidad precio de la demanda es
claramente mayor a 1 por lo que los
economistas consideran esta situación
como una demanda elástica mientras que
cuando pasamos del punto a al punto f el
valor absoluto de la elasticidad precio
de la demanda es definitivamente menor a
1 por lo que aquí tenemos una demanda
inelástica nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo